you
[Music]
okay we're happy to have you John Wong
do you pronounce your last name Wong
going Wow one okay we're happy to have
you Shang Wong here from CMU and he's
going to be talking about towards
practical machine learning with
differential privacy and beyond thank
you for the introduction my name is
Eugene Wang I'm from Carnegie Mellon
this is this talk is based on the joint
work with Steve Feinberg and Jinglei
that I work with Carnegie Mellon so
here's what I'm gonna do today I'm gonna
quickly talk about the motivation and
describe what's differential privacy is
for the sake of just getting everybody
on the same page then I will talk about
two of my work on differential private
machine learning and and and after that
talk about how they motivate us to
consider a weaker notion of privacy
called on average cal privacy and
describe its properties all right so
let's get it started so in the Big Data
era a company's governments and all the
data agencies are collecting a whole
bunch of personal data and for instance
on Facebook in your snapchat this is the
qpo in China and then companies are
keeping track of and recording down all
these user data when you interact with
their web services and try to use it to
maximize their profit and governments
use it for other purposes but the point
is that these are all personal data and
and people have different level of
conflict comfort level about like other
people using this data
with all this data what there are a lot
of things people can do for instance we
can use the data to come up with better
medical care more personalized education
and solve all the persistent social
social science problems and several
decades of research of machine learning
and like maybe a hundred years slightly
more than 100 years research of
statistics has given us a whole bunch of
tools to try to make sense of the data
models of data and and and draw
conclusions that will make the world a
better place but there's just one catch
with the increasing public awareness of
the privacy concern and maybe some new
privacy law it becomes harder and harder
for researchers to gather data to
actually make all these good things to
happen for instance the self is the
second Netflix price for movie
recommendation was cancelled in response
to a lawsuit regarding the privacy
concern and slightly more recently in
New York City when they released the the
taxi data immediately he got the
anonymized by by someone online but by
someone who actually graduated from
Carnegie Mellon and and yeah so so all
these things highlights a need for
formal messes with provable privacy
guarantees that protect individual level
data and and at the same time like we
have to also recognize that sometimes
maybe it's not the best idea to release
the raw data in the first place so we
need new ways to interact with still
assets so there are many approaches of
doing that tastes back to to the 1560s
in the statistics the community most of
this involves anonymizing the data by
removing personal identifiable features
and doing hey Alan
and things like that the thing is with
appropriate site information this kind
of heuristic way of getting privacy can
be really tricky and they are really
fragile under appropriate whenever some
sighting information is available now
this is what's happened with Netflix
when when people use like auxilary data
set for IMDB and they manage to - almost
exactly reconstruct the one-to-one
mapping from from users to users just
using their behavior data alone and such
site information a much easier to get in
the context of of big data era what
differential privacy do is that it
assumes that we are playing against an
adversary and differential privacy makes
no assumption on the power of the
adversary can have unbounded computation
and arbitrary site information what
differential privacy does is - instead
of having the adversary to access the
data directly
we now have an insulator between the
data and and and an adversary and
adversity you can ask questions
interactively and a curator is supposed
to somehow randomize the response so
that if the adversary do not know the
random outcome is oblivious friends like
in the term that's used in ETS it cannot
possibly identify any individual user so
let me illustrate differential privacy
with just one simple example of who
likes Justin Bieber suppose
okay all right
yeah suppose we have us new special
interest group about music and there is
a poll
do you like Justin Bieber yes and no you
don't have to answer this and everybody
everybody responded anonymously on this
web portal and at the end of the day the
the final outcome is released 30 people
in the New England lab said said yes
yeah this is might be a bit surprising
to everybody but since everybody
answered anonymously there's no reason
to to hide your preferences like I would
just trust this result so I came in
today as a visitor and Jennifer is kind
enough to allow me to participate in
this special interest group and IIIi did
and we repeat the same poll and
everybody responded and the answer now
becomes 31 so although I've no idea but
my privacy meaning that my third a
little secret that I actually enjoy
Justin Bieber a lot is now known to
everybody yeah that's a fair point but
suppose everybody answered faithfully
it's just like the previous day based on
the site information that's known to
everybody is that yesterday was surly
and I'm the only one that joined today
and responded to the poll like
essentially everybody knows my musical
preference and this might sounds pretty
amusing at at a glance but it can be
something else like instead of the
musical tastes music taste it can be
like suppose this is a poem about the
study for financial transactions or
maybe it's a sexual study on the sexual
assault on campus then just identifying
whether individuals responded to the
can be harmful to that particular person
so how will differential privacy resolve
this problem so instead of releasing
this the the outcomes directly a
randomized outcome so that we all we get
is a sample from from this distribution
so this serves as a smoother of the
outcome so that if you look at the two
distributions that centers at 30 and 31
suppose we had a large enough noise it
becomes harder and harder for people to
to tell which distribution actually
comes from and that gives a bit of
deniable of like plausible deniability
like in terms of statistics this adds a
fundamental difficulty in distinguish
between the two distributions based on
the Neyman Pearson lemma and the noise
level that we need to add is
proportional to the sensitivity of the
count function in this case it's just 1
again when we release this results
aggregate results in the differential
private way it's impossible for any
adversary to infer with enough
confidence which distribution which
world this this is this random
randomized outcome is from and we can
quantify how different this two
distribution is with with epsilon which
is what we call the privacy loss formula
suppose we calculate a log likelihood
ratio at every possible outcome H and
differential privacy requires that if we
take all possible outcome and if we take
all possible data sets that differs by
only one individual this log likelihood
ratio is bounded from above uniformly by
this fixed constant
civil alright I just want to highlight
that this is two supreme ones over here
so there are many convenient properties
of VP composes over small groups suppose
we want to protect in privacy of two
persons that of one and it just
aggregate on this pervasive laws it also
composes adaptively multiple access on
the data and it is also close to post
processing so this is a information
processing in policy off result and
typical algorithms are just either
adding noise adding Laplace noise will
give you pure differential privacy at
engulfing noise you will give you if
some delta differential privacy when
Delta is a cryptographically small
probability of failure and there's also
a more general approach of randomization
through the so called exponential
mechanism where this hero is some
quality function so instead of just
adding noise to the outcome like this
can be applied to cases when adding
noise doesn't really make sense I will
be sample from this distribution we
simultaneously guarantees epsilon
differential privacy and maximize
approximately maximizes utility function
here so let's get to the to the actual
part of my research on differential
private machine learning instead of
releasing just a single number so in
machine learning we make use of the data
by fitting it into a learning scheme it
can be just a classifier it can be some
unsupervised learning and I'll put some
representation of the data it can be a
function or can be represented by a
vector of coefficients
differential privacy the scheme of
differential private machine learning
instead of just learning this naively
you can you can use a randomized
algorithm so that the the such that the
outcome satisfies differential privacy
so the horizontal axis is a domain of
all possible outcome and vertical axis
is a probability just to make it more
concrete let's consider an example of
recommendation system so in model-based
collaborative filtering say Netflix it
uses the data set which we denote by Z
of the form of who rated which movie
which with which star and use a
randomized algorithm to come up with a
model and then later people can use this
model as a web service to predict their
their movie preferences in this setting
we trust a service provider meaning that
we allow Netflix to have the truth data
so it's not an adversary but other users
that makes use of the the web service
can be adversary's and since a is
differential a private prediction is
considered post-processing so so that's
secured to the data people use to train
this model before I go any further I
just wanna like highlight a high-level
idea of the synergy between learning and
privacy so privacy and learning are not
completely separate tasks for instance
if we try to build a classifier to
distinguish between cat and dogs and we
use the linear simple linear separator
and this gives us a compact
representation of the decision boundary
and and in some sense f is parsimonious
and
and that suppresses the the private
information on the other hand suppose we
bring a more complex method like neural
network or kernel based method sometimes
is prone to overfitting and like
sometimes we say that the trained
classifier memorizes in higher data set
so so that term alone would tell us that
knowing F would mean something that that
you have already breached the privacy of
individuals yeah so it's not completely
orthogonal tasks so so privacy and
learning are united by the fact that the
nisard has would like to come up with
some results that memorizes the data set
so it's well known within the community
of differential purposes that if any
outputs and learning algorithm is
epsilon differentially private that
implies that the generalization error is
bounded from above by by epsilon as well
and this states back to the very early
days of differential privacy
so the first oh yeah empirical risk is
supposed to come up with hypothesis H
the empirical risk is the evaluation of
that hypothesis with respect to the loss
function on your training data and the
risk is a expectation of the of the loss
function on new data yeah so so the risk
can be just the mean square error of
your predictive stars of movie
preferences an empirical risk is the the
the expected the means the mean square
error evaluated on the under training
data set so so this generalization
measure measures like how well your
algorithm will generalize to new the
if it's iits and the risk is for every
data point and this is like some more of
structural loss like like you don't when
you are using differential privacy yeah
but but usually in the statistical
learning setting you do as humanity but
our unknown distribution yeah yeah you
need to assume the data is drawn from a
distribution
depending on whether is I'd be the the
risk and empirical risk like are
calculated differently any bonding loss
right yeah for mean square error is
tricky because we also need to
constraint the domain so that it's
funded but say for four zero one
classification error then you don't have
to assume anything yeah so so the first
fundamental question that we ask is that
what can we learn privately
so the question addresses for every
given learning problem is there a
private learning algorithm that is
consistent in a sense that as we as a
number of data points go to infinity it
can be converges to the best possible
model that's representable within the
given class of models
just one data point in the training set
changes yeah yeah it doesn't have to be
the same but the distribution that that
is drawn from needs to be sufficiently
close right yeah it's a lot likelihood
ratio of the tool to district output
distribution needs to be bounded from
above uniformly by epsilon so like if I
am trying to manipulate a learner to
classify me as acceptance
right right interesting you're thinking
that this provides robustness
yeah yeah it is very much related to to
robustness and both games are and also
in the statistical robustness
so yeah this ignores the sample
complexity for any given the learning
problem this is just a yes and no
question and this was previously studied
impact learning like a while ago so so
we consider what generalize the view of
this learning problem so instead of just
the binary classifications in discrete
domain the back next general learning
setting contains a remarkably wide
selection of learning problems including
supervised learning unsupervised
learning density estimation and even
some of the modern learning paradigms
like matrix factorization like robust
pca matrix completion and other learning
tasks
yeah neural nets yeah near next to but
it doesn't contain these sequential
learning in paradigms like reinforcement
learning and online learn so let me just
quickly go through the notations for
statistical learning the data domain is
either if it's unsupervised learning is
just Z if it's supervised learning is a
feature and label pair and this
hypothesis class is pre specified by the
to define this learning problem that's
given by H and there's the loss
functions that map's
every hypothesis and every data points
to a real number this measures how well
this hypothesis represents this very
given data point and the task of a task
of machine learning is to statistical
learning is to try to find the
hypothesis that has lower risk and by
risk
I just mean is the expectation of the
last function
to a new data point form the same join
from the same distribution so what is
learnability again learnability is that
the existence of a learning algorithm
such that the risk converges to the best
possible risk representable from the
from the class age with a uniform risk
of convergence yeah
and private learnability requires that
they the problem to be learned learn
about by epsilon differential private
algorithm and similarly we can define
epsilon delta learnability
when it's learning over Y Delta DP
algorithm and Delta will goes to 0 at a
certain rate with respect to end
yeah if it affects the rate but supposed
to the number of data points to infinity
and this epsilon is a fixed constant
then you can always as a number of data
points gets larger you can most likely
not always converges to the optimal risk
you just consider a very low dimensional
model where the output space is like a
bounded compact domain as a ste
dimension and and so the naive learning
would give you typically give you four
square errors a do-over and rate so it
goes to zero agnostic Li and supposed to
add epsilon differential a private
algorithm to try to learn it and it will
be a randomized algorithm but a budding
expectation and by the expectation like
this additional randomness is fixed but
the number of data points would go to
yeah it's just
asymptotic
yeah yeah it has a lot to do with
stability which measures of measures how
much different the risk is when you
change one data points so so here's our
result we we characterize the the
private learner ability for web NexGen
or a learning setting and and for every
given learning problem we have we now
have a crisp statement that if the
problem is learn about is equivalent to
the existence of an algorithm that
asymptotic lay minimizes the empirical
risk so so so the converse of that
statement if is that if a problem for
every problem you cannot possibly find a
private algorithm to minimize empirical
risk then that implies that the problem
is not learn about in the first place
okay so so when I when I told Cynthia
about this like her response is that is
this a positive result or a negative so
I think it's a bit of both so the good
news is that now we can when we try to
find a private learning algorithm it
simplifies the pictures quite a bit we
can just focus on privatizing pure risk
minimization if it fails and nothing
will work in first place this motivated
us to to come up with a practical
generic algorithm for deep learning so
instead of statistical learning what we
do typically is to minimize the
regularized empirical risk and this R is
a sequence that depend on and that goes
to zero so it's empathically this is
empirical risk minimizer and using union
either union bound or uniform
convergence argument you can show that
this result is well being a well-behaved
and and the actually learns a problem so
in the private setting what we can do is
to use exponential mechanism
instead of minimizing the regularized
empirical risk we can sample from the
exponentiated distribution and like
since many of you guys are statistics
here like these are this is essentially
sampling from the posterior distribution
if you model the data using a patient
patient model and if you just chop this
is like sampling from the likelihood
exponentiated likelihood pile fish is
any prior any given prior it can be a
flat prior so you don't have to specify
any crime so anything you specifies
that's independent to the data so so pi
pi is like the exponentiated negative
log r yeah yeah for pokemon who suit
ones and yeah this gamma can be used to
tune like how much privacy's that you
need when the gamma is setting to be
something that's really large when it
converges to just empirical risk
minimization and if you comma is said to
be something small and you flattens the
distribution so we get more privacy
say again yeah so so so yeah in general
like I don't know you can use Markov
chain Monte Carlo in practice when this
L is a convex loss function then there
there are results that says that
sampling from this distribution is you
can do that in polynomial time by
running Markov channel the result from
the previous slide was the gen it had
nothing about efficiency no yeah
yeah yeah I wasn't yeah learning and
you'd okay about the raid Absalon yeah
yeah I should have said that in the
previous life yeah
so by the result of my sherry and how
are when lost function is bounded I
suppose these lost functions as
average of the empirical laws or the
some of the empirical lost in other
words when when this mountainous
assumption is true the sampling from
this distribution will give you a
differential privacy like in some sense
for free because that's what people are
doing in Bayesian learning in the first
place
alright so so so so we shows that
posterior sampling is asymptotic ly
normal like when when the model is it's
low dimensional like of course there's
also this regularity conditions like by
efficient we mean that it's nearly
optimal it nearly matches the Crimea row
lower bound up to a multiplicative
factor of 1 plus B over if it's not
yours
it's not complete yeah it's a
statistical education it means that not
like suppose B and Epson are both
constant they matches the the lower
bound up to a multiplicative fluency
these are the boundedness from here and
you can you can adjust what epsilon is
by tuning this gamma yeah okay and
dimension will go to premiere all over
the bank he comes in the Fisher
information yeah so it's like the
semi-definite auto range it's a
multiplicative pump so social dimension
would go to like the dimension will
affect the nonprofit learning and
private learning in the same way here
the dimension touch enters a pound if
you write the pound in terms of the the
empirical risk is accessors say the game
she's asking about sample admissions yes
okay
Sampo efficiency is is that sample
efficiency means that are you making the
best use of your data like in terms of
the non asymptotic sense yeah so so so
there's this crimea lower bound that
states that in terms of the number of
data points that you have right right
right yeah basically that that's that's
that yeah suppose you do the numbers
with in effect right right yeah you can
just use more theta2 right yeah so for
now private learning is like one and if
you need privacy becomes a 1 plus B over
epsilon I sometimes there are ways to
even get rid of this term but not in
general so we can actually sample from
the previous object if using a approach
called stochastic gradient Langevin
dynamics which basically simulates a
stochastic differential equation and and
besides that is differentially private
asymptotically if it mixes as we show
previously even if it does not mix we
can use at once composition and
subsampling lemma to construct an
approximate differential in private
upper bound so that like it's in some
sense differentially private in two ways
okay and also this is what people do
like in in the first place you basically
run stochastic gradient and you then you
add a calibrated sequence of noise to
your greedy
the samples are wrong I yeah so for
example if I wanted to formally ask
logic consistently in a network setting
as a number of notes go to infinity
right is it then it doesn't work yeah
but then you can you can consider to a
separate problem where resemble the
whole thing and then calculate the
generalization by the structural loss
when you simple like in the network of
the same science you can also calculate
the generalization and how will you do
with that given a number of size of the
network so and and we tried that on
Netflix data and yeah it worked really
well I mean really well in the system
sense in terms of privacy we can like
with sacrifice about like 15 percent of
the accuracy we are able to get this
epsilon differential purposes perhaps I
lost you about like 1 or something yeah
epsilon is one and we suffered like a 15
percent loss
kappa but but it's like yeah yeah right
right right that's like the marginal
case of whether this even is a
meaningful or meaningful yep yeah well
when you've see only so much larger than
one then it doesn't really make sense to
talk about the comparison so they're
also bad news so a lot of problems are
not actually privately learn about so
the picture may well like look like this
so one of the examples that people came
up with this the learning of threshold
functions
that's vc-dimension 1 meaning that a
non-profit setting you can learn it with
a constant number of data points random
samples and and this is actually a quite
a thin set so so for all the learning
problem is in a continuous domain when
the last function is discontinuous with
respect to the argument in H then you
can like physically state the same same
result and that's that's bad because
although we can learn things by just
running private erm but the kind of
things that we can learn more or less
restricted to the class of problems that
has Lipsius loss functions yeah
like I mean if you picked the
distribution on unlabeled points and it
takes that then
yeah yeah yeah if you fix the
distribution then you eventually go to
zero but but this brilliant higher set
of example you know yeah this Mesa like
I'm just saying that that's rate yeah we
don't have a lower bar yeah we also have
to same upper bounds yeah if it's not
this discontinuity discontinuity
yeah yeah then we know that you
continuous you don't know
[Music]
right 4:01 laws and basically continuous
domain or as a slumber of the size of H
is sufficiently large than physically
there is nothing to do yeah
so one may wonder whether epsilon-delta
differential privacy would help over
here so of course this depends on how
fast that we require this delta to go to
zero as a function of N and we show that
suppose this Delta is required to be
like relatively large then we don't
require very strong privacy guarantees
and anything that's learn about is also
approximately differentially private
learnable but that's bad because like
when this this thing is it's large then
we can just pick a random data point and
then just I'll put that and that's not
private at all so so it's really bad it
turns out right
oh my house got me to be right it her
cells a face from there's a sharper face
transition so whenever we require this
tells had to be on the order of one over
n then the same lower bound would apply
it and noting that since can be learn
about but there so it doesn't exist any
approximately differentially private
learning algorithm to actually learning
jeez yeah so so this is due to a result
of mark bomb for characterizing a sharp
rate of learning it's treacherous
functions
so the story so far is in general
learning setting also we can do private
erm and try to learn all the learn about
problems but many problems are not
private - they're vulnerable
and epsilon Delta D P does not help so
doesn't like this new thing called
concentrated D P because it's
essentially equivalent to if some Delta
DP yeah the thing is even if a problem
is had previously learn about like we
didn't say anything about the learning
rate it might not be practical at all so
when I was like traveling on different
conferences and talked to census people
and and other people were actually deals
with the data and use privacy tools to
try to come up with value they are very
frustrated with differential privacy
like to be honest and often you need to
add too much noise that ruins the
inferences and it gives really poor
utility and and the other to make it
work like when we try to do this Netflix
example it took us a lot of effort to
come up with tricks like clipping and
rescaling to ensure that the the last
function is funded by a not too big
number and to manipulate individual data
in a differential a private way so that
the whole thing is States differentially
private and give meaningful results
well there are a different level of
comfort for you like like we have a
notion called personalized privacy we
can allow every user to indicate their
their comfortable level of epsilon and
we can adjust that yeah for every person
separately so if you set your epsilon to
be really small then like 10 to the
power of negative 20 then essentially
we're dropping our data of the training
algorithm completely yeah so so so the
reason of all these is because
differential privacy is the worst-case
guarantee it protects the worst possible
data sets like if the independent is
completely independent to the
distribution that you join the data from
and and it only have something to do
with a domain that your data can
possibly be from so it's sensitive to
even one outlier in the population and
one peculiar curlier data set you can
construct from the given domain so so
let me illustrate that that with a
simple linear regression suppose every
user is x and y efficient label and we
have 100 of them assume x and y are
inside this park so the differential
privacy Y and we want to just fit a
linear regression this is as simple as
possible data analysis tasks that people
can try to try to do but say oh it poses
a big challenge for differential pairs
like we also need to assume the space of
the coefficients are bounded so that the
loss function is uniformly bounded from
above all right so what we do is to just
release through the posterior sampling
by adjusting this gamma will plot the
the privacy laws for every single gamma
so here here's what it looks like so so
this is like this purple line is the
access risk that's the actual like
utility of this learning algorithms and
detective that gives you and this is
like the the estimate of the
realization era yeah yes Lori's the
better lower is better for for
everything so the excess is just this
gamma when coming Slattery means more
utility and less private privacy and the
other way around and and this line is
the the loss if signal the differential
pirate loss like due to previous
discussion like whenever this is greater
than one that's here it becomes more or
less meaningless so this basically means
that at the intersection if we want a
non-trivial differential privacy
guarantee ISM we lose that by a hundred
times in terms of utility so it's very
hard to minimize the empirical risk when
you require differential privacy so
that's bad
so people has been trying to solve this
problem but but not by by a lot because
they are not willing to keep up the
distribution freakness of the the
definition of differential privacy so
the second question that we post we
check how much time
okay all right all right great so is
there some much much weaker notion of
privacy that we can define which
preserves the provable privacy
guarantees in the weak sense inherent
most of the desirable properties of
differential privacy and at the same
time give us a lot more utility in
practice
is there such a destination so that's
the discussion of the last part of the
top so recall that the definition of
differential privacy has to supremum
over here
the average KL privacy this is called
bilayer divergence tale simply replaces
both supremum with expectations so the
second expectation is taking over your
randomized algorithm and the first
expectation is taking over the
distribution of the data set as as well
as this small perturbation that changes
your data set by by one role okay so
this
second expectation but last one your
Forks are the same okay
this movie search has been generated by
a dependent dependent and then I say to
use in Spanish yeah learning so so so
the question boils down to whether the
adversary can condition on this claim I
claim that this notion of privacy are
like more reasonable a stability notion
it protects a typical user join from the
same distribution with sufficiently high
probability so that's the only claim
that I'm trying I'm not trying to
protect everybody because there are
people that do not care about privacy
and and and and yeah let's please just
bear with me and that's that's go to
like a really weak notion of privacy I
know people wouldn't like it especially
like yeah yeah but let's let's let's
pair with me and see like what we can
say about this new notion of privacy so
again like the second part is Kay all
that versions we can replace this with a
soup um we saw something between and and
the prime differential privacy is
essentially is a maximum of the max five
versions and this is just a different
measure of the difference of the two
distributions okay so it measures of
average privacy loss and these obviously
aren't affected by pathological cases
because we are essentially defining a
different epsilon for every data
generator
distribution and yeah and this is stated
for for its adaptive to every data issue
and the perhaps the best thing about it
is that we can now estimate that from
the data I the other word we can now
estimate a lower bound of the
differential privacy laws just from the
data okay what are the other properties
we show that this average kale have
received it satisfies most of the the
designing properties of differential
privacy including the small group
privacy like big group as well and it
composes over different multiple access
to the data adaptively and now
adaptively and it is also close to post
processing okay so so the composition
might be a little tricky suppose F is
this is a function of the data this is
epsilon Hawaii KL privacy private and
there's another function that possibly
depends on the F so condition on the
outcome of the of of F we can now come
come up with a new thing if and this
like and it is also randomized so we can
say that it is average payout private
but now this epsilon would depends on F
okay
so the composition would say that
suppose jointly these two procedures
will give you epsilon plus the
expectation of epsilon F where this
expectation is taking over the
randomness of
right yeah yeah yes yes yes okay yeah
sure yeah so that definition is also
defined and well you get you still get
close and suppose processing you still
get composition but you don't get
relaxed yeah so the thing is we now do
not need the nos function to be bounded
because we are sampling from like any
given loss and that's actually the case
when we do a patient model and we don't
specify abundance of the last function
but when the last function is indeed
bounded in the same algorithm would give
you differential privacy so so this
means that like there are two different
ways of looking at the same
randomization within your learning
algorithm like if it is P P the epsilon
might not be very small but we can
evaluate it in a different way and give
you a different interpretation in terms
of our average what's a privacy loss of
a typical user and that's going to be
others of magnitude smaller than what's
more interesting is that if we restrict
our attention to the class of posterior
sampling algorithm then this notion of
privacy actually characterizes a notion
of generalization called an average
general
yeah so so recall that previously this
expectation it's outside the absolute
value now if we push it back in like we
only need this to show like the
algorithm is consistent and and if so
our average payout privacy actually
characterizes the generalization error
like for each distribution separately
okay so this is really cool so called
corollary is that suppose we scale its
loss function somehow then is equivalent
to defining a new loss function that's
just a fraction of the original one and
we can use our everage payout privacy -
that's Epsilon to calculate the average
generalization error and and the and
also vice versa we can estimate privacy
by estimating generalization we can
estimate generalization by estimating
privacy so let's revisit a linear
regression example that I showed you
guys earlier like this is everything
that's on the previous slide what would
our average payout privacy be here yeah
oh by the way like the differential
privacy epsilon is upper bound of the
generalization error so there's there's
no issue here's where it is so the red
line is on average kale privacy as we
can see the from the worst case to the
average case we save for others of
magnitude of utility now we can at the
same place where the zip 0 equals to 1
we can get like nearly identical
performance like only a small loss from
the right hand side in terms of sax
access risk and also since I showed you
that on average kal purposely
characterizes generalization if we will
probably appropriately rescale it like
this is the estimated of general
estimation of generalization error
through privacy and we use the same
number of rerun of experiments as we can
see we get a much lower variance
comparing to if we estimate the
generalization directly yeah and the
theorem doesn't break because it's just
yeah
the generalization on kale privacy
expectation are exactly the same okay so
in summary we define a new definition of
privacy call on average kale privacy and
we requires no changes in the algorithm
a provides average case privacy and is
practically meaningful in the average
case especially when lives along in TP
is too large an even infinite we can
still get lungful results for this are
average notion of times a characterize
is a generalization for posterior
sampling and I think it's a necessary
step that we have a way to empirically
measure on privacy if we want to really
use it in practical applications so yeah
okay okay so so so I will feel have a
few minutes to talk about the future
work what I'm planning to do like maybe
three years to five years from now so so
first of all I think the other results
and this general topic that I presented
just now is a really exciting field to
be in because everybody nowadays care
about privacy and this intersection with
machine learning
Naza we have a way to estimate privacy
or a lower amount of differential
purposes Epsilon
in practice we can try to come up with
say a private machine learning
competition just like Netflix so anyone
can submit their own like randomized
algorithm and we come up with a bunch of
data sets that people care about in
practice and then evaluate the privacy
and utility of your algorithm and have
you later so that so that this can be a
competition that brings together
practitioners and and series because
like the way we evaluate privacy can be
like essentially the same as what
differential privacy protect against we
can run a deep neural network to try to
identify individual users by feeding the
output of the internal state of the your
released deep networks and then
substitute in data points and then you
get along really high dimensional
feature vector then we can try to
classify the feature vector with respect
to whether that particular individual is
used to train the network or not and if
we can do that then it means that it's
not private and if we can't even if we
are using the state-of-the-art machine
learning classifiers and it's likely
that like because we are already having
the most relevant site information
we're using the best tools available so
far then I would claim that in practice
like this randomized algorithm is pretty
good it's pretty pretty secure so so
Vitaly matakovich Malakoff has like some
preliminary results on this like using
deep learning to beat deep learning to
be private deep learning so it's really
cool and another thing that a take-home
message from the sequence of research
that I did is that statistical tools can
be really useful to boost the accuracy
and utility of differential private
readings so so one of the things people
can do is to do a post processing
because optimal post processing because
TP is resilient to any form of data
independent post process and in this
case it's very interesting because we do
not actually need to assume a noise
model as people are often doing
statistics now we know the noise model
exactly because that's from the privacy
we injected that and and also the
properties of true functions suppose we
try to release a histogram and that
histogram is known ahead of time and
usually in order to tune parameters of
certain statistical methods we do not
need the whole data set we only need
like some functions of the data set and
those like are just scalars and we can
release that like differentially
privately so there's a question of how
can we optimize the allocations of the
privacy laws over the entire pipeline
and that's like a future research of of
great interest so I will show my example
of how you can how well you can do when
you do post-processing comparing to not
to in post-processing at all and and
also there are a ways to learn from
aggregate data since the summary
statistics resident requiring the the
labels to be seen
every every data points so I also show
that some some of my my past research on
how can we learn from this label
proportions roses available and we can
randomize label proportions by adding a
little bit of noise for your privacy say
this can be your political opinion
whether you support Trump or or Hillary
and since like that a related field in
social science is called ecological
inference so so here's an example so
this is a regional data set from one of
the motivating application that's the
New York City Taxi data so I'm plotting
the the the number of taxi pickups
select a snap to the nearest street
corner of Manhattan and this is original
data that we try to release alright so
how do you really set privately what you
can do is because like at every hour
every taxi driver can add most pickup I
could say two or three jobs then you can
just add noise to every being with
variance with standard deviation
proportional to is that like limit
number of the number of tasks people can
do okay so that gives us is
differentially private release so for
people who don't know my work I also
work on a nonparametric regression in
particular this locally adaptive
nonparametric regression on grass okay
so we can just plug plug in like this
deeply reliefs which is a noisy
perturbed version of the original data
to a nonparametric regression smoothing
technique and get this if we compare the
original data and the noise to EP
release I would argue that like this
reviews more information and our cleaner
even be noise the
the original data so if we measure the
utility in a different way by assuming
original data is also generated randomly
with some intrinsic noise then I would
claim that by doing post-processing we
can even get a cleaner picture than the
original data and because of its
differential I perfect really is that
guarantees generalization so so we get
the best of both world writing in this
sense yeah so for learning from label
proportions here's our analysis on the
the election results from like magazines
these are these colors are results from
exit polls in the 2012 election between
Obama Romney we have an updated version
for Hillary and a trump but that's not
public yet yeah so so the task is like
based on based on only like basically we
know the label proportions for every
electoral regions and we also have the
individual level data from the Census
Bureau and what we did here is to
combine these two informations and try
to run ecological inference so that we
can fill in the gaps and get a finer
picture of the the results for womens
which which is in every electro regional
cross united states a ecological
inference is true try to like it's like
a Simpsons paradox so you try to learn a
more fine-grained fine-grained
statistics of the data by only observing
the total summary statistics like you
can't do that in general but with
additional assumptions a conditional
independence
assumptions you can do that preferably
yeah so this is one example of
ecological inference so as we can see
like this results are pretty consistent
in the states where we do have two exit
polls and there are a lot of like
traditional data that the additional
like inferences that we can wrong and we
really need to have some political
scientists to look at this picture and
see what what are the things that they
and stories that they can count on this
anyways like we can also use privacy to
help machine learning and statistics
because the generalize the type of
generalization that's provided by
privacy and maybe like just
randomization is a more robust notion of
privacy that's resilient to P hacking
all right
and we can use it to somehow automate
the entire pipeline of learning so in
conclusion this talk I showed you guys
that privacy and learning are
incremental related tasks through
generalization and and the same
randomization can give you different
interpretations of how much privacy
that's what you're losing I think he's
an exciting field and I will be very
happy if I hopefully get an offer I can
join you guys and work on these problems
together